angespannte ruhe am morgen nach den
angriffen in der nacht zu donnerstag auf
den golanhöhen
dabei ist der konflikt an der syrisch
israelischen grenze zwischen israel und
dem iran eskaliert erstmals seit beginn
des krieges im nachbarland griffen in
der nacht zu donnerstag iranische
revolutionsgarden nach israelischen
angaben armeeposten auf den golanhöhen
an die israelische luftwaffe reagierte
mit massiven vergeltungsangriffen auf
syrische militär einrichtungen und
iranische stellungen im nachbarland nach
israelischen armeeangaben feuerten
einheiten der iranischen
revolutionsgarden insgesamt rund 20
raketen auf israelische armee posten
entlang der grenze ab in teilen nord
israels wurde raketen alarm ausgelöst
die israelischen vergeltungsangriffe
zählten zu den schwersten seit ausbruch
des krieges im nachbarland 2011 bewohner
berichteten unter anderem von starken
explosionen nahe der hauptstadt damaskus
syrische medien berichteten
die luftabwehr raketen unter anderem
über damaskus und homs abgefangen